MANG: Good morning, my
friends and those fans
watching on YouTube.
I'm so delighted today to
welcome my friend, and my dear
brother, Jinpa-- Thupten Jimpa.
Well, most of you know
Jinpa from watching him
being next to the Dalai Lama.
Jinpa is, and has
been, the Dalai Lama's
principal English
translator since 1985.
Right?
Yeah, back when
even I was young.
[LAUGHTER]
In that role, Jinpa serves as
a bridge between languages.
He's bridging
Tibetan and English.
And he has been in that role
in other instances, as well,
translating many of
the Dalai Lama's books.
However, he's beyond that.
He's not just the Dalai
Lama's main translator.
He is an eminent scholar
in his own right.
He is the president of the
Institute of Tibetan Classics.
He is a chairman
of Mind and Life.
And he's a visiting scholar
at Stanford University.
And in that capacity, he created
the Compassion Cultivation
Training program,
the CCTV program.
And overall, he is one of
the most eminent scholars
in the world, on the
field of compassion.
So in that sense, Jinpa
serves as another bridge.
Jinpa is bridging some of
the most advanced teachings
in Tibetan Buddhism into the
modern world, to our world.
He's translating the
teachings in words
that even I can understand.
So that's just the
service he's providing.
In addition to that, having
known Jinpa for a while,
I can tell you--
in person, he is
just as you expect him to be.
Maybe better.
He is kind.
He's wise.
He's very gentle.
And he's too modest to tell you
this, so I'm going to tell you.
He is the model of
embodiment of compassion.
He's a model of what it's
like to use compression
to transform your life.
And so, he's here to talk
about his latest book,
"A Fearless Heart."
And with that, my friends,
please welcome my dear friend
Thupten Jinpa.
THUPTEN JINPA: Thank you,
Mang, for your very warm words
of welcome as well
as introducing me.
And good morning.
Thank you for coming and sharing
this morning brief moment
with me.
And I realized that,
actually, a large part of you
are trainees or instructors of
Search Inside Yourself, which
is a program that
Mang developed.
And based on that
program, Mang also
wrote a very successful book
that has been internationally
received so well.
And I'm delighted to be
spending this morning
with, particularly, the
instructors of Search Inside
Yourself, which I see as
a powerful and beautiful
combination of true great
insights of our time.
One is mindfulness.
And the other one is
emotional intelligence.
And I take my hat
off to all of you
who have dedicated teaching
this and spreading this
to the larger world.
It's also a joy for me to
be able to say a few words
on a topic that I'm personally
very passionate about,
compassion.
And particularly at
this place, Google,
which, over the
last decade or so,
has increasingly become
very important presence
in everybody's lives.
And that's a fact.
And so to be able to say
a few words on compassion
on the campus of Google has
a special meaning for me,
because I see one of the very
important aspects of compassion
is the universal
global dimension,
just as Google has this very
universal and global presence.
I see compassion as
probably one of the most,
if not the most, important place
in the interface of individuals
interacting with
society, individuals
acting with each
other, and cultures
and societies and communities
interacting with each other.
And I genuinely believe that the
time for compassion has come.
In some ways, the
realization of the importance
of compassion in
our society and time
has really been forced upon us.
And there are powerful
forces in our time
which are bringing the various
cultures and communities
of the world closer.
It's a cliche to say
that we are living
in a truly globalized world.
In the old days,
there wasn't much cost
to having a of world
that is parochial,
where you have a
slightly [INAUDIBLE]
sense of the importance of
your own version of history
and your own version of how
to structure a good society.
But now we're living in a time
where even these ideas, which
may seem, you know, part of
an individual's kind of bias,
have important implications
in how we relate to others
and how we interacted
with each other.
And in this kind of world
where, increasingly, we
are seeing through this
very close encounters
between cultures and ideologies
and religions and ethnicities,
we are beginning to see
pressures building up.
So then the question
is, how do we
equip ourselves to be in a world
where that kind of pressure's
brought to bear
on a daily basis?
And particularly
in the West, you
know, unlike some other
parts of the world,
western countries in
general-- and particularly
in North America,
like Canada and US--
are truly multiracial,
multiethnic, multireligious,
multicultural communities.
You know, we live in a time
and a world in our society
where, on a daily basis,
we interact with people
from completely different
background, people who look
differently, even physically.
So I think North America, as
a result of this experience,
probably has something to offer
to the larger part of the world
where people are struggling.
You know, we saw part
of that in France,
where there's a substantial
minority of people.
And, you know,
France as a society
is struggling to incorporate
that element of diversity
within there.
So I think these kind of
pressures are being built.
And also, His Holiness
often reminds us
that one of the plus
side of the growing
environmental degradation
is that it is reminding us
that we're living in one world.
We may have
different ideologies,
different national
policies, national interest,
but environment doesn't care.
You know, when things go
at the environmental level,
it doesn't care how
rich your country is,
how powerful your country is.
The impact of
environmental degradation
is going to be felt everywhere.
So that, also, is
reminding us that we
are in this all together.
So in this kind
of age, there are
pressures coming from
the societal structures
and changes, which is
really forcing us to come up
with a new way of seeing
the world, new way of being
in the world, a new way
of thinking about others
and ourselves.
And in this area,
I genuinely believe
the message of compassion
has a powerful role to play.
Now one could say, yes,
but compassion is something
that we humans have been
talking about and thinking
about for a long time.
If you look at all
the great teachings
of the religious traditions
going back to 3,000 years,
compassion is really at the
center of the ethical teachings
of these great traditions.
So the religions have been
teaching us about compassion
for all these years.
What is so different now?
You know, what makes
you think, or what
makes me think that that
message of compassion
is now going to be taken
more seriously when
it has been not taken that
seriously for all these years?
And here, I think
the new science that
is emerging that has to
do with understanding
empathy, understanding
compassion, understanding
the role of altruism
in development
of human behavior
and human evolution,
I think is making a difference.
Because in the past, we
have viewed and related
to qualities like
compassion and altruism
as part of the religious values,
something that we ought to do.
And when relegate these
values to something
that we ought to do, and part
of our moral value system,
then one of the interesting
thing about that
is that our relationship
with these qualities
acquire a flavor that
brings in a guilt.
When we think about
these qualities,
when we see, then,
the need in the world,
and when we are not able
to act out of compassion,
we feel guilty.
And guilt leaves a kind of
rather sour taste in our mind.
Because nobody wants to
feel bad about themselves,
then we tend to instinctively
learn to avoid, and even
instinctively turn our gaze.
And that is a dynamic
that we've develop.
But now, with a new
science, we're increasingly
realizing, actually,
these qualities
are really part of who we are.
They're a part of
our natural makeup.
I mean, although
historically, it
was the religious
traditions that really
took the responsibility
of spreading
the message of compassion and
love, [INAUDIBLE] of concern
for others' well
being and so on.
But in themselves, as His
Holiness often reminds us,
in themselves they're completely
independent of religion.
And now there are new research
showing that, in fact, you
know, qualities like compassion
and empathy are, in fact,
inborn.
Children as young
as six months old,
through some very, very
ingenious experiments
that were done by
some psychologist,
demonstrate powerful
preference to helping behavior,
as opposed to
hindering behavior.
There's a beautiful,
actually, experiment,
which is probably one YouTube.
You can see it shows
children watching
a video where there's a kind
of a cartoon, two characters.
And there's a slope.
And these cartoon characters
have been animated.
So there are images
of eyes and mouth
so that children can relate
to them as being, you know,
sentient.
So one object tries to go up.
And it keeps falling down.
And it goes up.
In one scene, there's another
object that comes from behind
and gives it a push to help it.
In another scene, the
same thing goes on,
but now this time, another
object comes from the top
and actually pushes it back,
so that it obstructs it.
And children show,
inevitably, preference
for the helping behavior.
And then, when they are given
the choice to choose toys--
and they did that with
all sorts of variations
of colors and shapes.
And they always choose
the one that helps.
So these kind of bias
towards helping behavior
is built in us very,
very early in our age.
And then some
interesting experiments
that shows that children about
the age of 14 months, they
instinctively engage
in helping behavior.
And this was done by a team
of two German scientist
from Max Planck Institute,
where one of the experiments
involve the experimenter
trying to dry clothes
on a clothesline, and
drops accidentally
one of the clothes pin, and
pretends can't reach it.
And the child,
about 14 months old,
looks, and then
immediately gets up--
and even though the
child may be playing,
gets up and picks it up
and give it to the person.
And they found out
that, actually, children
do this naturally
and instinctively.
But if you reward them,
they don't do it again.
So it's interesting.
And there's some important
message here for the parents
because I know in the West,
it's quite well widespread
that parents give money to
the children to do the chores.
So I think there's
some important lesson
for the parents here.
I resisted that.
And I managed to
convince my wife
that when children
were getting older,
we wanted them to do the chores.
But I said we will give
them weekly allowance.
But there shouldn't
be any direct link
between the money they receive
and the chores they do.
And I was so happy to see
that in those experiment
and felt that, OK.
My intuition was right.
So I think there all these
very, very cool findings
coming from science
that are increasingly
showing that actually
compassion is
part of our natural instinct.
It's actually part of
our natural makeup.
And furthermore, there
are more and more
research findings showing
that, in fact, compassion
is good for us.
His Holiness often
says that many people
feel that when they
listen to compassion,
and they think about compassion,
and they think about kindness,
many people feel
that to do compassion
and to act out of compassion
is good for someone
else-- the recipient--
and not necessarily
good for themselves.
But he says that, actually,
the first beneficiary
of your experience of
compassion is you, yourself.
Because your
compassionate act actually
brings about a material
benefit to the other
is dependent on many
factors, including
receptivity on the part of the
recipient, their state of mind.
And sometimes you may
have the best intention.
But what you do may
not be the right thing
to do in the right situation.
But when you feel compassion,
and reach out to someone,
at that moment you, yourself,
have gained the benefit
of experiencing compassion.
In fact, in my book I talk
quite a bit about this.
And I refer to
compassion as "the best
kept secret of happiness."
And that's one of the
paradoxes of compassion,
as well as happiness.
Because when we think
about compassion,
we, in a common sense or
intuitive kind of sense,
would say, OK.
Yes, when we feel compassion,
we are opening our heart.
We are making room in our heart
for someone else's problem
and situation.
It's a good thing to do.
But it's not
necessarily a way to joy
because one would, in fact,
expect additional misery
because you are
taking on more problem
than you, yourself, have.
But it turns out it's the
exact opposite, you know,
when we experience compassion.
And studies have
shown that people
who act out of kindness--
in fact, the psychologists
refer to it as
"the helpers high."
There's a chemical in the brain,
associated with the feeling
euphoria, gets activated.
And so that's sort of
an interesting paradox
because one would expect more
misery and distress, you know,
when you act out of compassion.
But exact opposite happens.
But if you think about
it, it's not really
that much of a
paradox because one
of the things about the
experience of compassion
and feeling of compassion
is, at that moment,
you feel deeply connected
with someone in front of you.
And that powerful
sense of connection
is very important part of human
aspiration and human need.
We are social creatures.
And our happiness
and our suffering
really is determined by the
quality of relationships
that we have with others.
There might be few,
you know, hermits.
Maybe one in a
billion, you know,
who will be able to be
in a total state of joy
alone, without needing
that interaction
with a fellow human at the
level of heart connection.
But that might be
one in a billion.
But for most of us, in
our experience of joy
and our experience of
suffering and pain,
really comes from the
quality of relationship
that we have with important
people in our life-- you know,
colleagues at work and
other people that we have
to interact on a daily basis.
So when you
experience compassion,
you really feel
connected to someone.
And in that state,
basically, one
of the important
things that happens
is that you learn
to forget yourself.
And it's this letting go
of your sense of self,
or self-awareness, that really
opens the space for joy.
So now take a step back and
think about all the times
when you felt most happy.
I bet the common
denominator is that ability
to forget yourself.
That's the paradox of happiness.
So if you really
want a true joy,
you have to let go of your
own self-consciousness.
And there's nothing more
powerful than the experience
of compassion to make
that possible for you.
So I think that that's probably
the reason why compassion
is the key to happiness.
Another important
benefit of compassion
is that, because of
this powerful dimension
of being able to identify and
connect with someone in front
of you, compassion is the best
buffer against the problem
of loneliness.
And loneliness is
increasingly becoming
an issue in contemporary
society because we tend
to live a more nuclear life.
And many of us live
also kind of alone.
And in that situation,
if you don't
learn to be able to connect
with someone important person
in your life at a deeper
level, whether it's
being part of a
community, or having
a healthy relationship, or
strong family connections,
loneliness is becoming an issue.
There was a rather sad data that
came out couple of years ago,
which showed that in the United
States, one in five people
report not having any person
in their life that they
can confide in.
Now that's terrifying.
I mean, we humans are not
meant to be living like this.
So I think here,
again, compassion
is really the best buffer
against that kind of danger
of loneliness.
And loneliness has real
impact on your own longevity.
There were studies showing, done
on old age homes, where people,
you know, who report frequent
experience of loneliness.
And it really correlates very
strongly with early death.
So it is costly.
It's costly.
I don't think we were even,
evolutionary-speaking,
meant to be living like this.
And another important
fact about compassion
is that when you're able to
experience compassion, and act
out of kindness, it
really creates a sense
of purpose in your life.
And there's nothing like
feeling that you matter,
whether it is at workplace, or
whether it's at your family,
whether it is in your
relationship with your friends.
When you know that
you matter, it
gives you a sense of purpose.
And sense of purpose
is, again, being
found as one of the
most important factors
in personal happiness.
And also there's a correlation
between longevity and sense
of purpose, as well.
So in all of these
areas, compassion really
does the trick.
And furthermore,
you know, for me--
someone who grew
up as a Buddhist
monk in the traditional Tibetan
Buddhist society-- you know,
living a moral and
ethical life is something
that is part of my aspiration.
And compassion provides
us a powerful anchor
of our personal ethics.
It provides us moral compass.
So when confronted
by a situation where
you are in a moral dilemma,
the best question to ask is,
what is the most compassionate
thing to do here?
So it really gives you a
kind of a moral compass which
really allows you to
be clear, you know,
what the priorities are.
And if the situation calls
for a tough, firm action,
it needs a fierce
compassionate response.
You know, compassion
sometimes is
misunderstood as just giving
in and just bowing down.
That's not really the case.
What compression does
demand in a situation
is that you never
lose sight of the fact
that the other person,
too, is another human being
just like me, who
wishes to seek happiness
and who wishes to
overcome suffering.
That much is really demanded
by taking compassion
as your main moral ground
to respond to a situation.
But if the situation calls
for a much tougher stand,
you can do it.
I mean, if you look at
people like Nelson Mandela
and Mother Theresa and His
Holiness, the Dalai Lama,
these people were
not weak individuals.
They were powerful individuals,
deeply compassionate,
but quite powerful.
And deeply committed
to what they do
and very strong in
their opposition
to injustice-- particularly
social injustice.
So sometimes we tend to mistake
compassion for kind of meekness
and just giving in.
And that's something that
we have to bear in mind.
So when you think
about all of this,
and also when you combine
this understanding
with the realization
that, actually,
compassion is part of
our natural instinct.
That's one of the
beauty of compassion.
I mean, if you compare
compassion to mindfulness,
mindfulness is something
that you have to cultivate.
You know, I think we
are naturally equipped
with a mind that
is very distracted.
There was a study that
shows that almost 50%
of the time, our
mind is wandering
even if we are supposed to
be focusing on something.
That was a study that
came out from Harvard.
So mindfulness is something that
we have to actually cultivate,
an acquired skill.
But compassion is
something that we are all
capable of doing naturally.
And especially people who have
the experience of being parents
know what it feels like to
experience an emotion where
the focus is completely
the other, where
there's no self-referential
or self-agenda involved.
A biologist, a cynic,
might say, yes.
You will do this because
the child in front of you
is biologically related to you.
All the rest and all the rest.
But the fact is,
actual experience,
the focus is
completely the other.
And your ultimate goal
of the interaction
is the welfare of the other
person in front of you.
That is compassion.
And that comes from
a powerful instinct
that we all have
that craves to be
connected with someone, this
nurturing, caring instinct.
And this, I think, is something
that we have to keep in mind.
Then the question is, if
compassion is so good,
and if it is natural,
how come we don't use it
more in our day-to-day life?
That's an interesting question.
And here I think we have
to take a step back and try
to understand.
Often, we bring resistances
with relation to compassion.
At the cultural level,
particularly in the West,
since the popular official
story of who we are as a species
really comes from Darwin's
Evolutionary Theory
and the survival of the
fittest kind of model,
and so there was a long
tradition in the West--
at least among the
scientifically educated
community-- that ultimate
explanation of human behavior
really must be rooted in the
pursuit of self-interest.
And competition is
the behavior that
manifest from this
pursuit of self-interest.
So its competition and
pursuit of self-interest
are seen as the ultimate
explanation of human behavior
and human evolution.
And so much so that--
I mean, when I first
went to Cambridge to study
Western philosophy, I was 30.
And by that time, my formal
training and Buddha studies
have already been completed.
And I was actually quite shocked
to realize how deeply embedded
this idea that, behind
every human behavior,
there must be some
self-interest element that
is the ultimate explanation.
And the reluctance on the
part of people to really allow
the possibility of real
truism, that was actually
quite shocking.
And then later, of course, I
came across these kind of ideas
more formally
presented in works.
And there is, in fact,
a notorious statement
made by an American
biologist who
said that "scratch an altruist
and watch a hypocrite bleed."
So those kind of ideas were the
official version of who we are.
And then when you have
that kind of idea,
then you become suspicious
of genuine charitable,
altruistic behavior.
You either see them
as, you know, abnormal,
some who are very special, and
some people are born like that.
And you don't really
relate to these qualities
as being part of your
defining character.
And also, individually,
we bring resistance
to expressing our
compassionate part,
partly because of this
kind of having bought
into this powerful narrative.
But also because in
the West, particularly
the contemporary culture--
increasingly in different parts
of the world, too-- our
society is structured
in highly a competitive manner.
And this competitiveness
is introduced
at a very, very early
age, from the word get-go.
From grade one,
we are constantly
exposed to evaluation, judgment,
and cross-comparison, and all
of this.
So we internalize sort of a
self-protecting mechanism that
shapes the way in which we view
our interaction with others,
and which colors our attitude
to things like compassion
and so on.
So then we expect these only
in a small, informal setting
of your own family
life and friends.
And at the societal
level, we don't really
expect these things.
So I think it's
these resistance then
we are afraid we bring fear.
We are afraid that if we are
too compassionate and too kind,
we will be seen as a pushover.
We will be seen as weak.
And people will take
advantage of me.
And sometimes we also worry
because in Western thinking,
we make very sharp dichotomy
between the rational part
of who we are and the
emotional part of who we are.
And going back all the
way to Plato's time,
that there is this conflict.
And because compassion
is seen more
as belonging to
the emotion camp,
people worry that if they allow
too much of their kindness
and compassion to take over,
that their rationality might
get dimmed.
They may not be, you know,
tough, that is required.
Their toughness
might be undermined.
So people, we worry, you know?
And also, even in parent and
children relationship, parents
worry that if they are too
kind to their children,
they might spoil the children.
And the children may
not learn the toughness
that is required in life.
So we bring all this kind of
fear and other resistance.
And that hinder the expression
of our compassionate part.
So what I present in the
book is to really make a case
that compassion does matter.
It is part of our
natural makeup.
And we can do
something about it,
so that we learn to, really,
not just leave compassion
at the mercy of situations.
Because for most of us,
we really leave compassion
at the mercy of situations.
You know, when it's triggered
by situation, we act out.
We allow it.
And when that happens,
the most beautiful part
of who we are really comes out.
Look at the overwhelming
response at the grassroot level
to the Asian tsunami, to
the earthquake in Haiti,
and now in Nepal.
The governmental level
responses may not
be forthcoming immediately.
But at the ordinary
people's level, you know,
international community
has been very generous.
But we leave it at the
mercy of situations.
We don't really make it.
But the point I'm trying
to make in my book,
as well as the idea behind the
Stanford Compassion Training
that I had the privilege
to help develop, the idea
is that we can do
something about it.
We can actually make
compassion a proactive stand,
and a perspective, or a
mindset, from which we
relate to our world.
And once we're able to
make it a proactive stance,
and then we get a choice
to be able to relate
to any difficult
situation-- both personal
as well as at the level
of community and society--
that we as individuals,
if we make the choice,
then we bring the best of
ourselves into that situation.
And whether it is in the
area of conflict resolution,
prevention of conflict, or
healthy relationship, when
we are able to bring
compassion, even to parenting,
it changes everything.
And we, ourselves, learn to live
with joy, because sometimes we
think that, well, compassion
and these things are wonderful.
But maybe sometime in future, we
will think about these things.
And we will.
And people get so caught in what
they are doing in the moment--
where it is job, or
making money, and so on--
and the people forget to live.
And life moves on.
This is where the Buddha's
teaching on impermanence
is very, very, very powerful.
The teaching on
impermanence reminds us
that the clock is
ticking all the time.
And if we don't learn to
live on a daily basis,
moment by moment, with joy
and with the best of our part,
then we miss, because you can
never go back and bring back
that time that is lost.
There's one of my
favorite authors
is this Czech writer,
Milan Kundera.
He wrote a powerful
series of essays
called "The Life Is Elsewhere."
You know, people who live their
life, thinking that someone
else is living a good life.
And, you know, they forget
that they're actually living.
And they forget to live.
And so this is why I think it's
important that, in the end,
being able to live your life out
of a compassionate standpoint,
you're the first one
to stand to gain.
Your relationships acquire
a different quality.
People enjoy being with you.
And also, you learn to
be at ease with yourself.
You know, those who have
had the chance to interact
with His Holiness,
you will recognize,
here is a person who is totally
comfortable in his own skin.
It's a refreshing energy.
And that kind of
freedom, that kind
of sense of abandon, that kind
of flexibility-- where he's
able to deeply delve
into a situation,
be completely empathetic,
and do the best to help, then
at the same time switch off
and move on to the next thing--
that ability to
switch modes and be
totally at ease with himself,
that comes from compassion.
And that is doable.
So then how do we do this?
And here, of course,
there's a whole program
that I've developed.
And, you know, those
who are interested
can visit the Stanford website.
But I would say few things.
One is, in our
day-to-day life, we
need to pay conscious
attention to,
what is the place of
compassion in my life?
How does compassion figure
in my hierarchy of value?
Even those of us who don't
see ourselves as religious,
we are still moral creatures.
You know, we are
emotional creatures.
We are rational creatures.
But also, we are
moral creatures.
And each of us, whether
articulated or not,
we have our value system
that organize our life.
And the values of those
things, principles,
that when you violate it,
makes you feel uncomfortable.
It makes you feel that
you haven't lived up
to your own standard.
Those are basically values.
I mean, values is a fancy word.
But basically, it relates
with those kind of principles.
And some of us, those who are
within the formal religious
setting, like Buddhism,
then we have a consciously
spelled out value system.
But majority, who live
a more secular life,
it may not be fully articulated.
But each of us has
a value system.
So then the question
is, how does it
figure within my own
hierarchy of value?
And to make it more important.
The second thing is to really
make conscious effort to,
as much as possible,
make compassion part
of our everyday intention.
Whatever we do.
One of the beautiful practices
from my Tibetan tradition,
is to-- every morning-- you set
an intention, to make this day
a meaningful, a purposeful.
You spend this day with more
mindfulness, more compassion,
and really pay attention to
how your behavior affects
other people.
So it's a very simple practice.
You can do it in one
minute or two minutes.
And so that intention-setting
on a daily basis, regularly,
really has the chance to
then shape our motivation.
And motivation is what
makes us do things.
You know, if we are angry
and feel kind of wronged,
we act out.
If we feel moved and
touched, we act out.
So motivation is a powerful
driver of human behavior.
But most of the
time, our motivations
are not very conscious
to ourselves.
Motivation is the
underlying reasons
why we do certain things.
Intentions are more conscious.
Of course, sometimes
in everyday English,
we tend to mix the two,
as if they are synonymous.
But they're not.
Intention has a more
directed goal, an objective.
Motivation is more of
an underlying reasons
why we do certain things.
And the way in which
you shape the motivation
is to consciously
shape your intention.
And if you're able
to bring compassion
as part of that intention,
there is a chance
that it will become part
of your motivation system.
So once we're able
to do that, then we
will be able to bring greater
awareness into our life.
So when we are content
with the situation,
then awareness kicks in.
And this is why like
mindfulness-type practices,
like contemplative
practices, are so powerful.
Because contemplative
practice brings three gifts.
One is attention--
ability to pay attention.
Second is to bring
conscious intention,
so that you can live your
life more consciously.
And third is the ability to
bring greater self-awareness
into a situation.
So this is through training.
And when I speak of
training, I don't
mean to confine it
to just commitment
to every day of formal sitting.
If people can do it,
that's fantastic.
But that's also,
some people are not
inclined to that
kind of approach.
But you can pay
conscious attention,
bring intention, and
become more aware.
And in this way, we can
really change and transform.
And in the end, if
we are able to live
our life from a
standpoint of compassion,
it really acquires a
totally different quality.
And the Buddha was right when
he said that with our mind,
we create our own world.
Effectively what
the Buddha is saying
is that, although we may be
all living in the exactly
the same physical environment,
but the world that each of us
experience is very different.
The differences
come from the way
we perceive the world,
the attitudes we
bring into the world, and the
values that shape our outlook.
And that changes the way we
feel and experience the world.
And that changes
the way we behave.
And how perception
changes in our feeling
was powerfully demonstrated by
a very simple experiment that
was done, where subjects were
sitting opposite each other,
looking at their own monitor.
They were asked
to wear headgear.
And then they were listening to
a same music at the same speed.
And they were asked to tap
their fingers according
to the rhythm.
So in one set of experiments,
they all tapped in synchrony.
In another set of
experiments, they
were listening to
different music.
So they tapped differently,
without synchrony.
And afterwards,
they were exposed
to a situation where
one of their partners
was unfairly penalized.
And they observed the response.
And in those situations where
people tapped in synchrony,
they expressed much more sense
of concern for their partner.
And in the other
group, where they
were tapping not
in synchrony, there
wasn't that kind of
stronger sense of concern.
And if you asked
them, they wouldn't
know that that
was the thing that
was, you know,
influencing their attitude
and feeling about this person.
So the point here is
that if we consciously
learn to view
ourselves and others
from a standpoint of
compassion, it really
has the power to change the
way we feel about others.
And that holds promise
for transformation.
You know, because when we think
about spiritual transformation,
sometimes people think about
something far down the line.
But actually, really, I mean
you can, on a day-to-day life,
it makes a huge difference.
So let me just read few words
as a form of conclusion.
And then I'll take
some questions.
"When we make a
habit of compassion
in our everyday lives through
regular practice an action,
we live with more courage, less
stress, and greater freedom.
In time, we will automatically
see ourselves, and the world,
in terms of interconnectedness.
Our default position
towards other people
will be as fellow human
beings, rather than sources
of antagonism and threat.
Our new, other-oriented
habits will free us
from the old habits
of self-judgment,
self-protection, and
worrying about ourselves.
Our relationships, from chance
encounters with strangers,
to our intimate connections with
our closest family and friends,
will be permeated with a sense
of openness and kindness,
rooted in the understanding
of our fundamental human
condition-- our shared
needs, vulnerability,
and the basic aspirations
for happiness.
We will habitually respond
to all people suffering
and needs with compassion,
unprejudiced by who
they are in relation to us.
Even when it comes to
a difficult person who
causes us problem, we will
not lose sight of the fact,
just like me, he, too,
is a fellow human who
aspires to happiness, and
does not wish to suffer.
These thoughts will have
entered our fast system.
Our actions, too, will reflect
our deep, even cellular,
knowledge of the impact
we have on others.
Our habit of kindness will
be reinforced over and over
by the joy we take in
being kind to others,
and seeing them happy.
Being helpful will
be our new normal.
We will come to
embody compassion,
not just admire it as an ideal.
We will learn to live it
through our thoughts, feelings,
and behavior.
In short, making a
habit of compassion
will transform our lives."
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In acting
with compassion
to others, what is our
responsibility for thinking
about their existing condition?
And by acting
compassionately to them,
are they going to
feel an obligation
to act compassionately in
response to someone who they
may not be in a position to?
And will that lead
to resentment?
Do we need to be
worried about that?
THUPTEN JINPA: That's a
very, very good question.
Actually, I think
when we act out
of compassion towards
someone, on our part,
I don't think there should
be an expectation of how
they would respond.
Because when we bring an
expectation on our part,
then it puts pressure
on the other person.
Because a true
compassion is motivated
by just a thought of wanting
to do something for the other,
and regardless of
how that other person
may receive the extended hand.
And that's why, sometimes, a
true compassionate response
to a situation may be simply
to let the other person know
that you are there, available,
not necessarily doing
something.
And sometimes a situation
calls where what is needed
is just an understanding
and a more apathetic ear,
rather than some solution.
And this is why compassion,
to act out of compassion
is, you need a
little bit of wisdom.
One of the beautiful
things about compassion
is that it offers us
the ability to respond
to suffering without
completely being,
you know, pulled by the urge to
do something about, and solve,
the problem.
And especially for
men, like, we are not
very good at dealing
with situations where
there is no obvious solution.
We freak out.
[LAUGHTER]
Women are much better
at this, probably
because of their
maternal instinct.
You know, sometimes
with children,
they are throwing their tantrum.
But they're screaming
their heads off.
The best response
is just to be there,
not to react, but to show
understanding and empathy.
And show the child that
when he or she is ready,
the mummy's ready, you know?
I've raised two kids, my
younger daughter is 16
and elder one is 18.
I had a very easy life
with the elder one.
But the younger one, when
she was between two to four,
was a real challenge.
And that's when I
realized, actually,
even someone like
myself-- who have
come through the
monastic training
and always felt that I had quite
a strong reserve of patience,
I say that in my book-- and I've
never experienced in my life
where I've been driven
to being so mad.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think the most
important thing is not
to impose upon the recipient
some kind of expectation.
And when people know
where you're coming from,
then people are very dignified
in the way in which they will
receive or, you know, say, OK.
I don't need the help right now.
So here you have to resist from
being what the Americans quote
"busybodies."
[LAUGHTER]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What advice
do you have for people
who are managing people?
So, managers.
And are there any
particular practices
you recommend for people who
are in positions of authority?
Thanks.
THUPTEN JINPA: Very,
very good question.
I think, now here, I'm entering
the territory where I don't
really have much experience.
I mean, the only
management experience
I have is really
the monastic area,
monastic community, where I was
a member of a community that
had about 400 monks.
And I was involved in the
administrative side of that,
partly because I was one of the
few who actually spoke English.
[LAUGHTER]
But I've always found it, in
my own role in the management
kind of experience, that when
you make clear where you're
coming from, when your
intention is clear,
people are always much
more accommodating.
So I think that kind of
clarity is very important.
And then, also, many of
us struggle with our egos.
And often, ego comes in the way.
And in fact, human beings
are very, very complicated
creatures.
When there are more
than two people,
there's already a complexity.
And often, much of
the problem really
comes not so much from the
challenge of the actual world,
but really the challenge of the
dynamics of the personalities.
So here, if you are especially
more in the leadership
kind of position, if
you are able to bring
an element of kind of
egolessness-- it's tough--
but if you're able to bring
that, it really sets the tone.
I have been the chair of Mind
and Life institute for now
about four years.
And we have a very large
board, about 12-13 people.
And I also noticed, not just
in the monastic setting,
but here too, when I'm able to
bring the best of my intention,
with no self-concern
about my ego,
and it completely
changes the dynamic.
And it also sets the
tone for everybody else
to bring their best.
So I think that's
one important lesson.
And also, sometimes
in a management,
you have to make very
difficult decisions.
And you have to learn
to give the bad news.
And here, I think a
little bit of training,
and there's always a
more compassionate way
of conveying this news.
And this is something
that-- because in the end,
people are very, very
forgiving and understanding
when they understand that
you did something because you
had no other choice.
And you did it with full
consciousness, and also
a sense of concern.
And people, they take
it less personally.
The experience of
hurt is very painful
when the recipient
of that decision
feels personally
discriminated against.
Somehow, when the person
takes it to be personal,
that's when it becomes
much more painful.
So that's one suggestion.
And at the level of
authority, I don't know.
I mean, I just hope--
Bill George has just left.
Bill George is
involved with Mind
and Life Institute in a
very interesting project
call ACEL, Academy of Ethical
Leadership, where the Mind
and Life Institute is trying to
bring principles of compassion
and empathy in leadership role.
But I think there is
now people are beginning
to think about how
to bring mindfulness,
how to bring compassion,
into this kind of equation.
But at the moment, I think
the dominant paradigm really
is not that.
I mean, I even read-- with
horror-- some articles
in the "Scientific
American" a couple of years
ago how, in fact, some kind
of psychopathic, you know,
attributes are good in
an efficient leader.
So, right now, that current
kind of paradigm is really that.
But I think mindfulness
and compassion
is beginning to make inroads.
Because in the end,
even from the point
of view of the
leaderships themselves,
at the personal level, they are
all individuals like ourselves.
They're worried
about their family.
They're worried about
their reputation.
they're well being.
They're worried
about their fame.
They're all individuals.
And even from the point of
view of their own self-care,
something like having a
more principled approach
to their leadership role is in
their own personal interest.
And those kind of realizations
will gradually come.
AUDIENCE: I had a question about
the Good Samaritan experiment,
about how the
person who was going
to give the lecture on
the Good Samaritan, when
they were rushed, wouldn't
help someone on the way.
And I've been
wondering for a while,
from the perspective
of compassion,
what is actually going on?
And I'm asking specifically
in Silicon Valley,
where the competition between
companies has a lot of rushing.
There's a lot of,
who can be first?
And it's just part of our jobs.
And so I'm trying
to understand what
really is the
mechanism for being
rushed undermining compassion?
And what is it?
Is there a particular
focus, or practice,
in terms of compassion that
can help to ward that off?
THUPTEN JINPA: That's a
very, very good question.
And I've also read that study
and was quite intrigued.
But I understand, because
when we are in a rush, OK,
our attention completely shifts.
And in order to be able to
tap into your compassion,
you do need to allow the
attention to be there.
Because without attention, you
don't understand the situation.
And without understanding
the situation,
you don't connect
with the situation.
And for us to act
out of compassion,
we need to feel that
connection, or identification.
And when we are in rush,
we don't allow ourselves.
And especially if you're
rushing to an important meeting,
even before you are
physically there,
mentally, you're already there.
And it leaves no room
for us to actually allow
ourselves to be attentive
to the need in front of us.
And so this is an
important factor.
And when we think
about this, people
start thinking, OK, then that
means you need a lot of time.
But that's not true.
Attention, awareness
of situation,
and connecting
with the situation,
these all things
happen very, very fast.
But we do need to allow
that initial space.
And this is what
is not happening
when people are really
rushing, and especially
when they've already
rushed with their mind.
Now, ideally, if
we take compassion
as part of our daily
experience more seriously,
then we will be able to learn
to be more in the present.
And then even if you have
to rush to a meeting,
you know, while you are walking,
your mind is still with you,
instead of your
mind already being
there, which then prevents
you from being able to connect
with what is in front of you.
So that's probably one factor.
But as to the larger question
of this highly competitive,
fast-paced culture,
I don't know.
I mean, the influence of
Silicon Valley's discoveries
and invention is
just so, so powerful.
And I just wish
that, once in awhile,
people in the
leadership position
would take a step
back and reflect on,
what is the large implication
at to societal level,
with all these things
that we're bringing out?
Recently, the Apple
brought out the iWatch.
You know, I just hope that
their motivation is not just
selling us another need,
with making more money.
If that is the case,
it's troubling.
But on the other hand, the world
is so driven by economic needs.
And countries and
companies constantly
come up with their
quarterly reports,
and growths
projections, and so on.
And in this kind of
highly charged, kind of,
pressure approach, I
don't know if people
have the time or the
space to step back.
But there is a kind of
a moral responsibility.
Although most people
in the actual business
may argue that it's
none of their business
how people use the
technology what is on offer
is up to the
individual's choice,
but at the same time,
that's not completely true.
Once you change the culture
through this technology,
everybody has no choice
but to participate in it.
Because, otherwise, you are not
part of the larger community.
So in these kind
of situations, I
hope there will be more debate.
But surprisingly,
there hasn't been much.
When biotechnology and genetic
modification of biological
organisms were taking place,
in Europe particularly,
there was a huge amount
of debate-- you know,
among the academics,
the intellectuals,
among the leaders
of the industry--
and which really shaped the way
in which the whole industry,
you know, was
eventually unfolded,
with the labelling
and all of this,
which I thought was a very
responsible way of dealing with
new reality which
has been created.
And the power of the
digital technologies--
when we invent a new product
which becomes very widespread,
we're actually
creating new reality.
And new reality demands
a new ethical response,
responsibility.
But we, often as a
society, we don't
rise to that challenge of coming
up with a critical discussion.
And so I don't know.
I mean, at some point,
this neck breaking speed
has to slow down.
But at the moment, it doesn't
seem to be slowing down.
MANG: So we are very lucky.
This book is basically, in a
way, Jinpa's coming out party.
[LAUGHTER]
What you don't
know about Jinpa is
that he's actually very eminent
and famous in the Tibetan
Buddhist community for being a
very highly respected scholar.
And this is his coming out,
out of their community,
into our world,
the modern society,
and coming out as a
teacher for the rest of us.
The book is "A Fearless Heart,"
available where books are sold.
And my friends, Thupten Jinpa.